- Good morning Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe and I
believe that you have something
special, that when you unleash it,
it will be able to change the world.
And so to help you on your
journey, today's message
is break the rules.
Over to you Simon Sinek.
(rooster crowing)
(upbeat music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'.
♫ I wake up every morning.
- Let me tell you a story.
So a friend of mine and I,
we went for a run in Central Park.
The Roadrunners organization,
on the weekends,
they host races, and it's
very common, at the end
of the race, they'll have a
sponsor who will give away
something, apples or bagels or something.
And on this particular
day, when we got to the end
of the run, there were some free bagels.
And they had picnic tables
set up, and on one side
was a group of volunteers.
On the table were boxes of
bagels, and on the other side
was a long line of runners
waiting to get their free bagel.
So I said to my friend,
"let's get a bagel".
And he looked at me and said,
"ah, that line's too long".
And I said, "free bagel".
And he said, " I don't
want to wait in line".
And I was like, "free bagel".
And he says, "nah, it's too long".
And that's when I realized
that there's two ways
to see the world.
Some people see the thing that they want,
and some people see the
thing that prevents them
from getting the thing that they want.
I could only see the bagels.
He could only see the line.
And so, I walked up to the line.
I leaned in between two people,
put my had in the box,
and pulled out two bagels.
And no one got mad at me.
Because, the rule is, you can
go after whatever you want,
you just cannot deny anyone
else, to go after whatever
they want.
Now I had to sacrifice choice.
I didn't get to choose which bagel I got.
I got whatever I pulled
out, but I didn't have
to wait in line.
So the point is, you don't
have to wait in line,
you don't have to do it the
way everybody else has done it.
You can do it your way.
You can break the rules.
You just can't get in
the way of somebody else
getting what they want.
That's rule number one.
- So I'm not necessarily a huge
advocate of cutting in line
to get what you want, and
I think it's mostly because
it's getting what you want at
the expense of somebody else.
Right, like you're cutting in
line, and that means somebody
else is losing out.
It's the same thing for me when
I'm driving and there's this
really long left turn lane.
I hate when people suggest,
like, hey, just drive up
on the right side and at the
last second kind of cut in.
Because, to my own benefit,
I'm screwing over the people
behind me.
I don't think the world
has to be that way.
Like, you can go and see
the world as, I'm going
to make things better for
myself, and in the process,
help everybody else, instead
of hurt everybody else.
So I think that's what entrepreneurs do.
And I think in terms of
breaking the rules, anytime
there's a rule that I feel
is really holding me back,
I'm frustrated.
Understand that most rules
were created by people
who were just like you, who
were no smarter than you,
and they're created for
the average person, right.
It's like how average people
should live their life
and should operate and that
could be very frustrating
for somebody who doesn't want
to be average at something.
And so it's understanding,
what are the rules
that you can break,
and then, from an
entrepreneur's perspective,
how do we do that in a way
that can serve other people.
I think that's one of the
key differences between
entrepreneurs and the rest of
the world, is that when we see
something that we don't like.
When we see a rule that
is really frustrating,
most people will just complain.
They'll complain, they'll whine,
they'll tell their friends,
they'll post on social media.
They'll just get really
upset, where entrepreneurs,
we will still get upset,
but we'll use that anger
and frustration, and turn
it into something positive.
Out of every crisis, out of
every negativity, out of every
frustration, there's a
positive, there's something
that can be created on the
other side that can solve
that frustration, not
just for us, but for other
people as well.
And the bigger that
frustration is, the more people
complaining about it, the
greater the opportunity there is
to create something really
really meaningful and special
for the planet.
So I think the key
understanding is to figure out
which rules you can break,
and which ones you shouldn't.
If you just follow life around
and you follow every single
rule, you're never going
to create anything amazing
extraordinary, insanely special.
Because you have to be a bit
of a rule-breaker to create
something new, otherwise you're
just living an average life.
But if you're breaking every
single rule that ever exists,
you're probably going to end
up dead or in jail, really,
really, really quickly.
And so it's understanding what
are the rules you can break,
and again, having that
perspective of, I'm going to break
this rule, not just to help
myself, but I'm going to help
the people around me as well.
So, the question of the
day today, is I'm curious,
what is a rule that you have
broken recently, that has
helped you and helped
the people around you.
Really curious to find out.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Tom Bennett.
Tom, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really appreciate the
support, and I hope you enjoy
the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever Your One Word is,
much love, and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for
another shot of Entspresso.
(upbeat music)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'.
(typing)
- The people who because the
most successful in our society
are people who broke the rules.
You know, there was no presidents
for 24 hour news cycles
until Ted Turner did it.
There are so many people
who got out of the box.
Look at Apple and the birth
of the whole notion of Apple,
or Nike, I talk about in
the book of the birthing
of that corporation.
How they did something with
the tennis shoe that had never
been done before.
If you only base your
decisions on empirical data,
you can only repeat what
somebody else already did.
If you follow your instincts
and your own God-given
creativity, we could go where
we have not been before.
And our nation used to do that.
- We have so many rules
in life about everything.
I say, "break the rules, not
the law, but break the rules".
My wife has a t-shirt that
says, "well-behaved women
rarely make history".
Well you know, I don't want to
burst a bubble, but the same
is true with man.
It is impossible to be a
maverick, or true original,
if you're too well-behaved and don't want
to break the rules.
You have to think outside the box.
That's what I believe after all.
What is the point of being on
this earth, if all you want
to do is be liked by
everyone and avoid trouble.
The only way that I ever
got anyplace was to breaking
some of the rules.
After all, I remember that
after I was finished with
my body-building career, I
wanted to get into acting,
and I wanted to be a star in films.
You can imagine what the
agents said when I went to meet
all those agents.
Everyone had the same line,
that it can't be done.
The rules are different here.
He says, "look at your body,
you have this huge, monstrous
body, you're overly
developed, it doesn't fit
into the movies".
You don't understand.
This was 20 years ago,
the Hercules movies.
Now, there is the little
guys, to name, Dustin Hoffman,
Woody Allen, Jack Nicholson,
before he gained weight
of course, that is.
But anyway, those are the guys that win.
And the agent also
complained about my accent.
He says, "no one ever became a star
with an accent like that, especially not
with a German accent."
And yes, I can imagine with
your name Arnold Schwarzen,
Schnitzle or whatever the
name is, on the billboard.
Yeah, that's going to draw
a lot of tickets and sell
a lot of tickets, yeah, right.
So this is the kind of
negative attitude they had.
But I didn't listen to those rules.
Even though there were very
nice, and they said, "look,
we can get you some bit parts.
We can get you to be a, playing
a wrestler, or a bouncer.
Or maybe with your German
accent we can get you to be
a Nazi officer in Hogan's
Heroes or something like that."
But I didn't listen to all this.
Those were their rules, not my rules.
I was convinced I could do it.
That if I worked this hard
as I did in body-building,
five hours a day.
And I started getting to work.
I started taking acting classes.
I took English classes.
I took speech classes, dialogue
classes, accent-removal
classes, I even took.
I remember running around, "a
fine wine grows on the vine."
Is it because Germans have
difficulties with the 'F'
and the 'W' and the 'V'.
So, "a fine wine grows on the vine".
I know what some of you
now say, is the hope
that Arnold got his money back.
But let me tell you something,
I had a good time doing
those things and it really
helped me.
Finally I broke through.
I broke through and I started
getting the first parts
in tv, Streets of San Francisco.
Lucille Ball hired me.
I made Pumping Iron, Stay Hungry.
And then I got the big break
in Conan the Barbarian.
(audience cheering)
And there, the Director
said, "if we wouldn't have
Schwarzenegger, we would
have to build one".
Now think about that.
And then, when I did
Terminator, "I'll be back",
(audience cheering)
became one of the most famous
lines in movie history.
All because of my crazy accent.
Now think about it, the
things that the agent said,
would be totally a detriment
and would be impossible
for me to get a job, all of a
sudden became an asset for me.
All of those things, my
accent, my body and everything.
So, it just shows to you,
never listen to that you can't
do something.
And,"you have to work your
way up, of course, run for
something else first".
I mean, it was the same when
I ran for Govenor, the same
lines, "you have to work your
way up, it can't be done".
And then, of course, I ran
for gGovenor, and the rest,
of course is history.
They said you have to start
with the small job as Mayor,
and then as Assemblyman,
and then Lieutenant Govenor,
and then as Govenor.
And they said that's the way
it works in a political career.
I said, "I'm not interested
in a political career. I want
to be a public servant. I want
to fix California's problems
and bring people together and
bring the parties together".
So, like I said, I decided to run.
I didn't pay attention to
the rules, and I made it,
and the rest is history.